okay well welcome I gotta say thank you
people thank you PayPal for coming all
this way is this microphone to [ __ ]
loud no it's [ __ ] perfect
like always holy [ __ ] okay anyway we
made it guys we are at they [ __ ] end
Act five forever and I'm gonna tell you
this game has been going on far too
[ __ ] long okay I'm kind of getting
tired of this [ __ ] is this my [ __ ]
broken I [ __ ] it okay so where were we
we saw that shout we went upstairs let's
just get this over with there was you
what happen to open this up because
usually they yell at you yeah oh so it's
still the same animation even I'm
underwater [ __ ] dog underwater
it has attained you'd look for a better
way nothing is ever easy
when the tide rises give it choose the
easy
yeah that's so weird it's like every
time we go through that door that game
like [ __ ] ends or something so I
guess all right oh we saw most the story
okay so let's just get going
tired of being underwater [ __ ] dirty
in here so gonna step on her now be
[ __ ]
the last real it's yeah Shay this movie
is well do it a 'speedrun [ __ ]
because the [ __ ] tardies man against
well that's the Stars though
man this guy this [ __ ] boys actor
must be milking it at the back right now
baby he's drinking a martini after this
work hell yeah baby
the eyes of eternity are once again upon
me yeah
okay
forever act 5 let's do this [ __ ] this
place feels so familiar like I've been
here before and yet I cannot find my way
there has to be a way
hello sir ah disgusting do you see now
you tried to fix me instead you broke
yourself
what is [ __ ] eating sweets to the
sweet bitter for the bitter are you
saying they under water
so he's going [ __ ] nuts now
is this unlock now
holy [ __ ] hey keep flipping it
this guy's coming this guy is [ __ ]
coming yeah it looks like [ __ ] that
trogdor [ __ ] whoa
I can't bet you up and out well I tell
you honestly when I was like I'm gonna
tell you when this game came out well
and there's a for you're one came out I
was like oh [ __ ] it's sick like I really
like to see how good 3d people are going
[ __ ] nuts with like horror you know
because like a lot of good tribute stuff
like [ __ ] inception that movie when
things are spin and she like that all
that stuff should be cool people talk
about it but when people get like
[ __ ] free rein it's interesting and I
was alright like they do the painting
thing painting you see a lot of good
options you know because you could
[ __ ] start like what's going on here
you could start like flipping things
anyway this yeah hey it goes this do
some crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] luck unlock
yourself in here and I was like okay how
far can he go
and they did pretty good but I thought
that was it and then later for your Tiki
Mountain I'm like alright it's a
different setting you know it's about
how far can you go but I gotta be
surprised they did a lot of crazy [ __ ]
like unpleasant surprise that how many
crazy things they could do like this is
[ __ ] nuts actually okay let's say
yeah let's say here hey the other place
what is it
hey yeah Oh places if I can go in really
I would an can't close it
okay [ __ ] edge so just what a handle
on missing handle you know no no no
[ __ ] handle here we go like there's
like a lot of to be things like visually
it's stunning you think that like how I
don't know it's hard to explain it's
like how many crazy things today imagine
there's a lot of crazy [ __ ]
they got a [ __ ]
let's do this [ __ ] let's do this
[ __ ] I hate that now like that this is
do and I stand wasn't last time there
was like a [ __ ] okay I guess I'm done
here
wait is there instructions on what I
gotta press yeah
was it
and I really see what the clue is
any [ __ ] clues here there's a heart
can't get in here now everybody's got to
go deeper
okay handy let's go whooping eat these
got the booth you meet me hello Sachin
so look at summary what happened this
chap last chapters just figure what the
[ __ ] is going on storyline to be honest
I don't [ __ ] know other than like
James and this girl were like separate
at some point you have [ __ ] he got
[ __ ] traumatized and how long has it
been
I don't remember anymore start to
remember feel myself slipping growing
thin and it keeps growing it won't let
me go was he talking about general words
what is this
okay so anyway it really happened is
this [ __ ] hurt
yes anyway they didn't [ __ ] mention
all the seven allusions your foot oh
they said I think in the summary I was
like reading it was like they found
Lily's head in a bag in the end and I
was like no that was just a [ __ ]
allusion to the movie se7en
like have you ever watched seven I think
we so sick to be the [ __ ] audio
engineer for this the sounds are [ __ ]
amazing in this game like they he did a
good job
yeah shut out all [ __ ] Erica it's gonna
burn away should be another [ __ ] fire
[Music]
this time I don't think
I cannot okay
si means yes I thought I was the kid
have a batch
unless it's like a symbolic thing dude
if I director something like that I
would not do a movie I don't know if I
was - quite sure well a director kind of
Benetech what was that a rat
see this is things of shining
I don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
hey God Bank not today I actually don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm supposed to do
that was [ __ ] depressed now
you know I constantly hear someone
eating and that's like so [ __ ]
starving I don't know why I think it's
because like if you hear something you
just imagine there to be like an entity
in the room but there's just not and
it's [ __ ] scary okay
there's that [ __ ] okay
[ __ ]
see this is so crazy holy [ __ ] this is
the [ __ ] movie in my room wherever I
go it follows I can't be free but a
formless shadow my shadow keeps shifting
changing and I change with it
I think this is my place and that no
noisy
[ __ ] dirty place dirty please get
your tat and the shot say they've done a
hand always before it can't have my
white [ __ ] not disgusting get the [ __ ]
out of here
[Applause]
yeah okay
a lot harder I had the bay well
everything's so [ __ ] slow in here I
can't [ __ ] move I just
okay you shut that [ __ ] out that much
is certain
money don't mind if I do
I may be just in general a little piece
of slower hey I did that that's about to
go in there
I am the safecracker
cool
is it can this is great
all right yes I got a dude here
okay it's there a batch
he's [ __ ] [ __ ] that way
this is a [ __ ] mess in here where's
the [ __ ] maid okay good matter to be
honest but it's a [ __ ] disgusting
okay help yourself okay Eric cows get
back no Church us
alright [ __ ] here did don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
here I guess when I come in I guess and
come back in there you guys you gotta do
it here
oh the [ __ ]
okay which way do only a turn or an
event triggers oh yeah the [ __ ] see this
is crazy this is crazy
[Applause]
now I [ __ ] made it
you [ __ ] just cheated that's behind
me
hey they plays television I'm so bored
please some television sir
he is gone hey stare at Pepe gonna happy
I pass huh the events on computers now
this sounds like ending music ending
music
no mr. Barrow
[ __ ] I gotta go
finally understand their way out it's
here that's me me yeah how are you [ __ ]
am I supposed to know I I'm looking
[ __ ]
what I was doing here can I leave it
hey Sam at because they're not looking
at
now I don't crumble that's for cookies
all right
I win hand days what what what what is
that you know I do a lot of crazy [ __ ]
should I do it turns up and on I fry
should've Dutch dad I'm not a [ __ ]
mechanical engineer but it's whatever oh
this is but here's the full story then
here we go
you destroy the other there's no other
way look the rat run you caught away the
strings
you hesitate you'd look for a better way
nothing is ever easy
tired why should you choose the easy way
there they
[Music]
you have to
okay
[Music]
okay
that's disgusting
so at the beginning of the game again
we're flying through this [ __ ] whoa
I have ends we're very nice Johnny the
dreams all we love is stripped away is
he eating a [ __ ] mannequin oh boy I'm
asleep I'm a mistake and yet there is
still hope you see
although the boy has ceased to be where
there was I shall be we the holy flame
I think his eyes are glowing I was gonna
give me there's another one let us be
together forever
okay I don't know that kind of lost
causes eating [ __ ] porcelain I'm sure
you'll find me quite a change okay yeah
this kids a little kind of gone
bravo Bravo everybody
bravo Bravo everyone thank you thank you
and I thank you honestly you can file a
resume I like nothing I am [ __ ]
beautiful so I am the adult version of
the kid
wait I did that
sir I was just that way you know if I
didn't read the synopsis I'd be like I
don't know what the [ __ ] this is
I'm so talented
I'm perfect
[Music]
what's in that box
[Music]
what's in there the [ __ ] was that all
right well that said Babis that's that
all right wait designer get people holy
[ __ ] 3d artists only two 3d artists holy
[ __ ]
Lana and Justyna man they did a [ __ ]
phenomenal sound designer Bruna great
holy [ __ ] I guess the poor gamer should
we feel good there's a lot alike if
you're looking this way change this
that's be cool
Barbara is hate to purchase from our 3d
artists holy [ __ ]
okay now they had a shit-ton artists the
[ __ ]
maybe these are just like not 3d art
it's just like visual effects artist
Michael block Allah okay then I got
vocals various Vendetta
music sound engineers that's not talking
about okay it's [ __ ] straight there
that's thank you thank you
voice cast director Tony Todd he's
[ __ ] dark the rat queen of the narrow
neck Glen moister a lot of [ __ ]
people on here anyway
it's pretty good a little long but
pretty good you know definitely a feat
of strength when it comes to like a 3d
animation she liked that but I thought
the store was kind of confusing I feel
like I've read everything okay yeah
anyway really good game thank y'all for
watching